>> Now that you've calculated the standard deviation by hand, we can finally do
it with spreadsheets. And that's what we're going to do from now on. Open the
spreadsheet called Sample Social Networkers Salary. The link should be at the
right. This has 100 data values and you're going to calculate the standard
deviation. You'll have to copy this into your own spreadsheet. To guide you,
I've listed instructions, and they have numbers that signify the order in which
you should do them. So first find the average of these values. Then you find the
deviation. Then you square each deviation. Then you find the average squared
deviation. And then finally, you take the square root. And this is the standard
deviation. Once you've calculated the standard deviation, enter it here.